okay so I got a pretty crazy story for
you guys today
I'm one hand we have the former CEO of
Thunder gaming who has alleged history
of making false promises and misleading
investors and then on the other hand we
have the small-time youtuber who broke
down those false promises and called the
guy out for it and now funder gaming and
our CEO are doing everything they can to
shut this guy up including filing a
cease and desist letter this is
Christian Bishop the former CEO of
Thunder gaming and one-time star of The
Bachelorette
and this is the youtuber technicals who
called out Bishop on his history of
false promises on December 24th
technicals posted this 30-minute video
breaking down why he thinks Bishop is a
con man I first knew about Bishop like I
went to this event Hyrule Saga and he
saw me and then he offered me like all
his production equipment he's like off
you want to go on stage we got this and
we got that later I find out that
they're having all these issues with
community right like their production
quality terrible and one of my friends
this was the tipping point he starts
reaching out to me he's like hey you
want to look into Thunder gaming man cuz
they're they're a little bit weird he
talks about how Christian made a bunch
of money in a couple different fortune
500 companies and then pivoted to
eSports and created this production
company called GG media network his
whole plan was to create this like
Hollywood level quality like eSports
content that was his whole goal because
this real Hollywood movie and then in
2016 this company called American
leisure Holdings merged with GG media
and Christian became its CEO when so
when mergers typically happened it's
with one big company who can provide
more opportunities and money for you to
do the things that you want to do and so
in Bishop's case this was an opportunity
to grow his production company and make
the videos that he set out to me but
then technicals goes through all of the
quarterly reports that MLH actually
filed and they show that they were in a
[ __ ] ton of debt and we're in no
position to fund this production company
he's got the financial analysis websites
that were raising red flags about AML H
long before the merger actually happened
so the merger happens but then people
pretty quickly start asking questions
when it becomes
clear that bishop is not making anything
like none of the content that he
promised was actually happening and then
when people actually started raising
concerns he just deleted everything Gigi
related from the internet and the reason
why I'm reading transcripts off of
investor hub a TV FN is because
Christian deleted everything he deleted
the company page and the company Twitter
no longer exists and there's even a
bunch of tweets from some pretty
pissed-off investors and so like at this
point I'm wondering why GG and AML h
merged in the first place and when I
asked Bishop about this he says that the
YouTuber technicals didn't actually
explain the full financial story you
know and one of the shots he brings up
financials like of the company um
typically around the details of saying
oh look at this business Christians
wasted all this money Bubba bought those
financials where the financials of the
business when I took it over but you
leave out the fact that if you look at
the financials there were never even a
salad breeze taken I didn't take a
dollar from the business and company so
yeah bishop basically says that he
inherited this shitty financial
situation and that he actually never
made any money when he was CEO and so
from bishops perspective he was
presented with an opportunity to help
turn around a failing business in AML H
which if it became profitable would help
expand GG media and guess what it just
it didn't pan out it didn't work and
yeah he made mistakes he ignored
shareholders and the deleted GG social
media presence when things started going
south but the way he talks about it he
never tried to screw anyone over I'm not
gonna make any money from this business
unless I can get it on its feet so you
know going nearly two years without ever
collecting a paycheck from the company
those are actually I took so it's to
talk like this guy's malicious he's
taking advantage of people and
shareholders but then you leave out the
fact of he never took up a paycheck he
never took a dollar he literally didn't
make a single dollar from his business
he was working to try to make this thing
work and build a company here or without
ever taking a dollar that's a really big
fact now I thought hey maybe they're
having a rebrand or just some technical
issues so I went back and checked their
social media presence and yeah
everything's gone it's all good
yeah GG medias Twitter and website are
still gone and forecast which was
supposed to be the flagship Hollywood
quality eSports news show hasn't tweeted
out since 2017
now just because GG media didn't produce
any of the content that Bischoff
promised doesn't mean that they didn't
try in fact they shot a whole pilot for
this news show that they were looking to
produce they poured a ton of money into
it they hired a PR firm that works with
Disney and they pitched it to a lot of
different big cable news channels but
similar to a MLH it just didn't work
none of the network's that Bishop
pitched the show to wanted to do it and
that was a pilot that was a show had one
of the I think challenges of that
particular business was we try to go to
the traditional Hollywood route we hired
you know consultants from g4 or the old
gaming Network into people and started
producing you know pilots and programs
and we went out and we got ripped by a
PR firm that did a lot of work with
Disney and we wanted fought the
traditional Hollywood fight it's like
take the pilot out there on the road
pitch it try to get it funded and you
know got our bus kick like out in market
right spent the money produced the pilot
made the show and actually had that
brought in the actors the writers and
the talent did all that work so then you
have this YouTube we're calling out what
looks like unfortunately pretty typical
eSports behavior right struggling
businesses a bunch of empty promises
ignoring shareholders all of it and here
is where Thunder gaming comes into the
picture on January 29th 2018 a.m. LH and
Gigi media quote entered into a
strategic alliance with Thunder gaming
based out of Long Beach California in
order to develop produce and promote
original programming in the gaming
category end quote and as a part of that
alliance quote Christian Bishop has been
appointed the CEO of Thunder gaming and
will oversee its day-to-day operations
Gigi Media Network will move its
headquarters and operate out of thunder
studios end quote
and so Thunder gaming is the eSports
subsidiary of thunder studios and
thunder studios is this well-funded
production house that made this
Hollywood movie in 2017 with Charlie
Sheen and Whoopi Goldberg and so
theoretically with GG media now working
with thunder studios and having access
to lots of money
would think that Bishop would finally
come through and make the content that
he promised and no they they didn't do
that okay so now Bishop a CEO of Thunder
gaming they still haven't come through
on the promise of making Hollywood
quality level of content but they decide
to get involved with the fgc they signed
a [ __ ] ton of smash players hosted a
bunch of tournaments that were well less
than perfect and really just try to make
a name for themselves they're your
typical eSports org insanely fast growth
they're a little rough around the edges
but they seem genuinely invested in
their communities okay so now the
YouTuber technicals drops in this video
right calling a bishop making fun of
thunder gaming all on Christmas Eve and
yeah it caught on quickly it was all
over the fgc reddit it blew up on
Twitter
Thunder gaming blocked technicals and
then Roderick David the guy who created
thunder studios well he got involved so
we have this got dramatic quick and
remember this is all happening over the
holidays now this part is insane
two weeks after the video was released
thunder gaming social media team posted
this cease and desist letter to Twitter
now a cease and desist letter is
basically a warning right it's somebody
saying hey we don't like what you're
doing and if you don't stop we might end
up taking you to court in this case the
letter basically says that the youtuber
technicals lies about Bishop lies about
thunder gaming and to really just cut
the [ __ ]
so they post a cease and desist letter
to Twitter but technicals the person who
needs to see it can't because they've
blocked him and then they deleted the
cease and desist letter entirely and
actually talked to our lawyer about this
he says that like yeah you could email
them the letter you could even DM it to
them if you wanted to but you can't just
post it to Twitter hope that they'll see
it and then call it a day that's not
really how it works and then on top of
that the cease and desist letter
included all of technicals personal
information including his zip code and
nobody blacked it out
so yeah they [ __ ] doxed him by
accident and then someone else told me
hey dude they left your zip code up
there too I was like oh yeah
they pretty much yeah they pretty much
ducks I was like ah dude this isn't cool
there's people like in there telling me
like what one of my cross streets were
and [ __ ] and I was like [ __ ] like
and then yeah they were like telling me
the full name of my girlfriend and all
this like so I had to start private
information on my facebook because I
don't use my Facebook and I don't want
my family in like loved ones to get
harassed and then like I said they
deleted the tweet and then posted
something else about how they were
revamping their social media policy
whatever that means now Bishop believes
that Thunder gaming did actually
physically mail the letter to technicals
but when I asked technicals about if he
had received anything he said no nothing
he hadn't received anything and so in
the midst of all this Bishop just left
Thunder gaming he moved on to two other
jobs with another eSports company but
was still consulting for Thunder gaming
and still partly owned the company it's
all very weird and confusing so we have
this hotshot CEO who wanted to make
Hollywood quality eSports content
he ended up merging with two different
companies and got everything he needed
in order to do it and then he just
didn't do it and then this small time
youtuber calls him out for it the
company he works for goes after the kid
online and then Bishop just leaves and
that brings us to now technicals posted
a couple other videos making fun of
thunder gaming a bunch of Twitter beef
broke out like eight players decided to
not renew their contracts with Thunder
gaming although none of them really
explicitly stated if it was because of
this mess or not now obviously there's
still a lot of ongoing parts with this
story
so if something else pops off I will be
sure to let you know and I was at Tim
Hortons on the weekend and some [ __ ]
dude wanted six milk and six sugar and
then like freaked out when it was
incorrect and I was just gonna it was
like a funny story like he was like he's
like this doesn't taste what I wanted it
to taste like I asked for six milk and
sugar in my coffee
and this [ __ ] guy's just losing it in
a Tim Hortons on a Sunday morning and
I'm behind him being like this [ __ ]
loser like come on yeah
right you're not drinking coffee at this
point you just wanted like liquid sugar
that's all you wanted